man hat das Gefühl was mache ich dir
eigentlich warum muss ich jetzt hier
sein und das machen das ist natürlich
frustrierend
belastend blüht wo es Pflege Adventures
Schlacht Gott Sinn am Limit in der
letzten Jahr haben die immer mehr den
Job auch geschmissen und suchen
wie sie Patientinnen und Patientinnen
ein Konflikt mit der eigenen
Wertvorstellung mein Name ist
also moralische
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
stressig ist
[Musik]
aufgefallen dass die pflegende
und es ist einfach eine Möglichkeit
und ich freue mich schon wie können Sie
mit dem Stress um
sie findet gar nicht mit der
Pflegefachfrau mit wo am Unispital Basel
schafft
also ich mache einfach jetzt mit der
Manu und ihr seid im Hintergrund
gucken uns mal diese Wunde an
also es wird ganz kurz kalt
das Pflaster zuerst
das ist das Entfernung Spray das
florscht eine klappt
damit tun
ja auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall
zwei Hände mehr
am liebsten zwei
man ist frohmittel Hilfe die man hat da
liest so gespürt der Pflegenotstand
selber im Team sie verzählt mir dass es
immer wieder Leute gibt wo mit der
Situation in der Pflege
man stellt sich vor in der wunderschönen
perfekten Welt dass man alle Zeit der
Welt hat und bei seinen Patienten
Patienten zu sein
und sich für alles so viel Zeit nehmen
wie man halt gerne möchte aber die
Realität sieht anders aus
was macht das mit einem wenn man die
zieht nicht hat
also du hast einfach konstant diesen
Konflikt mit dir selbst bedeutet ja du
bist mit der Behandlung der Patienten
nicht ganz zufrieden du hast das Gefühl
der Patient ist über oder unterversorgt
und hast das Gefühl es könnte eine ganz
andere Richtung gehen vielleicht und
dann ist der ethische Aspekt sehr
wichtig der für uns ein sehr sehr große
Rolle spielt
man macht sich Gedanken darüber ob das
wirklich ist das Richtige ist natürlich
und man hat das Gefühl was mache ich dir
eigentlich warum muss ich jetzt hier
sein und das machen das ist natürlich
frustrierend
belastend
stressig
so wie eine Last die man auf sich trägt
wie eine große große Last
ich spüre dass der lissabont und sich
mit ganz viel Liebe und Engagement für
ihre Patientinnen und Patientinnen
es ist schon mega früh es ist immer noch
dunkel ich bin gerade auf dem Weg
aushalten das ist der Moritz Rolli
Coiffeur Lehrer angefangen
Blut im schweizerischen Gesundheit
im Jahr 20 30 bis zu 55 pflegen
guten Morgen
freut mich dass wir jetzt
zwei Jahre ist
und scheint richtig befreit sind
ist
jetzt macht er der zweite Ausbildung
moralische Konflikt wo so entstanden
ja
das geben psychisch nun
schlafen
ausgemacht hat oder wegen der Biss
vergessen hat
das Richtige ist wo man macht ob man
mehr hat sauber machen
Bundesamt für Statistik über 100 55000
Personen in der Pflege rund 7000 Stellen
sind momentan
[Musik]
im Gesundheitssystem ich habe das Gefühl
erstens als Patient wenn ich
wenn ich selber mal
ins Spital ist die und ich mit Rede
und ich dann merke da hat einfach
Übelkeit sitzt das macht mir Angst was
macht man auch Angst wenn jetzt
überlegen wenn
ja wenn jetzt zum Beispiel meine Eltern
oder meine Angst im Spital dann sind
dass sie vielleicht
häufig ist im Spital fürs Personal wie
ich sie jetzt gerade erleben einfach
hektisch und stressig
eins zwei drei
das machen sie sehr gut mit dem
Festhalten super guten Appetit danke
schön
wie lange sie
muss man jeden Tag
ankreuzen was man alles gemacht hat und
hier unten steht wie viel Zeit man mit
dem Patient oder Patientin verbraucht am
Tag also wie viel aktive Pflegezeit man
investiert hat das und das 395 Minuten
die gestern dokumentiert sind aber es
sind immer immer mehr ich spüre
zwischen den moralischen ausspricht und
Tempo möglich ist
dann
schaue ich
dass ich priorisieren kann wenn er meine
Zeit braucht wegen
wegen irgendwas was ihn belastet und der
gerade das Gespräch sucht und Redebedarf
hat
dann versuche ich es schon zu
gewährleisten
das ist eine sehr gute Frage
also man lernt mit der Zeit dazu
ich bin bei weitem nicht perfekt ich
habe sehr sehr große Schuldgefühle und
mache mir auch zu Hause teilweise Stress
das ist aber nicht gesund
so doof ist sich anhört aber
Zeitmanagement und Prioritätensetzung
ist schon mal ein guter Ansatz aber
eigentlich müssten überall gleichzeitig
sie oder ist das genau genau also wir
haben das zum Beispiel sehr oft wir
haben halt diesen Konflikt man sagt ja
wenn so viel zu tun ist und wenn so viel
Personal fehlt dann versucht man halt so
ethisch wie es geht irgendwelche
Abstriche zu machen in der Versorgung
wenn man zum Beispiel gestern Haare
gewaschen hat dann wäre ich von heute
nicht mehr Haare mit den Patienten die
es nicht selber können man möchte zu
Hause auch nicht jeden Tag die Haare
aber es gibt halt Abstriche die man
nicht machen kann wenn jetzt jemand im
Sterben liegt der regelmäßig
augenmundpflege benötigt Gespräche mit
den mit der Familie mit den Angehörigen
und wenn eine andere Person
tiermotherapie hat das ist auch ein ganz
ganz striktes Prozedere dann musst du
halt in diesen beiden Zimmern
gleichzeitig sein da kannst du keine
Abstriche machen dann ist es einfach so
genau
[Gelächter]
wieso muss ich das wird
wir gehen jetzt in den Ausguss
die werden
Blut Urin Fäkalien entsorgt
schmutzige Wäsche entsorgt
meine Grenze ist da erreicht wo ich das
Gefühl habe ich gehe nach Hause und
meine Patienten sind nicht so betreut
wie es mir vorgestellt habe
ich spüre mit deiner Lied von das sind
wirklich müde
und manchmal kommt das nicht wirklich so
wie sie das sich wünscht und wo das noch
Jahre nicht
gedacht ich brauche
ich treffe sie fürs Gespräche in der
Altstadt von Zürich
hallo bist du Jasmina Büro
dann ist das Kind zum Glück wiedersehen
ich möchte immer so schaffen
das Erlaubnis mit dem Säugling ist aber
nicht einzigartig es hebe immer wieder
Situationen gehen wo sie ihre Job nicht
machen und
ja und das irgendwie
Situation die anderen Arten können
Teamkolleginnen
und ohne Zeitdruck dass man einfach
vielleicht
dass man auch wirklich
gefährlich
muss machen
das ist für mich auch jetzt im
Nachhinein ist das wirklich belassen sie
ich kann zum Beispiel Hexen
konzername geschlafen gemacht
hätte
der moralische Stress Plage zum neuen
Job nehmen
[Gelächter]
und das ist eben auch noch schöner
oder ich kann es Mittagessen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
es ist mega emotional sieht das Gespräch
mega
oft gesagt was ist stört und was besser
muss werden und man hat sie einfach
gehört und es tut mir leid jetzt müssen
verabschieden
[Musik]
guten Morgen
es hatten ihnen die Nephrologen
und Steam immer noch viel wichtig im
Gegensatz zu die Jasmina Robel hat sie
aber immer noch das Gefühl dass ihre
Arbeitgeber sie wertschätzt meiner
Meinung nach kann man Moral distress
also dieser
dieser interne Stress mit sich selbst
und dieses Unverständnis der Therapie
gegenüber
vermeiden indem man
sehr sehr gut mit den Ärzten und Ärzten
kommuniziert das heißt
offene Kommunikation mit allen
Disziplinen ist unglaublich wichtig
guter Beziehungsaufbau zu deinen
Arbeitskollegen nicht nur andere Pflege
und Pflegerinnen sondern auch die
Kollegin von der Physiotherapie die
Kollegin und Kolleginnen von der
Ärzteschaft sei es Oberärztin Oberärzte
die Assistenzärzte die für die Patienten
zuständig sind dass man halt wirklich
konstant in diesem Dialog ist
alle müssen verstehen dass alle den
Patient betreuen nicht nur die
Ärzteschaft sondern wir gehören ganz
ganz eng zum Betreuungsteam dazu wir
sind nonstop am Patient und an den
Patientinnen
sehr
sehr wichtig das wird zu sagen das
Wichtigste
das wichtigste Station dass meine größte
Team hat
sehr psychisch belastende Situationen
und ohne gutes Team wird es Verschnitte
natürlich
man ist gerade am Leben der Menschen
dabei man kann daran teilnehmen ich löse
gerade die Stau schlau man kann daran
teilnehmen man bekommt sehr sehr viel
Dankbarkeit zurück
dürfen sie gerade hier den Finger drauf
legen
sehr gut super
das ist nicht nur das klassische Lächeln
was man zurück bekommt oder das die
klassische Dankbarkeit die man gezeigt
bekommt dass man halt so oft hört oder
das danke was man zurückbekommen das ist
so so viel mehr es ist
man ist bei den Menschen eigentlich
hautnah dabei wie sie noch ein bisschen
drauf wie sie Diagnosen bekommen man ist
vorher währenddessen nachher dabei
man ist mit ihnen mit ihren Familien
danke schön bitte dürfen sie wieder ganz
frei bewegen
bis später
[Musik]
ich bin auch froh dass ich nach all dem
Frust auch noch glücklicher
creme ich meine sie macht das wirklich
mit Herzblut der Bruder wenn ich mir
vorstelle dass ich selber müsst ins
Spital dann habe ich eigentlich schon
aus
gefühlt sondern einfach nach all dem was
ich jetzt gesehen
ja noch alternativ sprechen
und das gespart werden muss und das sind
und doch wenn jetzt Pflegefachkraft wie
zum Beispiel
unsicher fühle
aber ich muss Gefühl wenn ich daran
denke dass ich Patientin wäre was danke
dir was haben wir für Erfahrungen
gemacht ich liebe es mir doch in
Kommentar und abonniere den Kanal